what's up guys hope you guys are doing
well here's a quick update on where
bitcoin stands today it's currently a
742 billion dollar asset
the inflation rate is at 1.79
89 of all bitcoin that will ever be in
existence has already been entered into
the circulating supply
there's been over 8 billion 8.7 billion
dollars of on-chain
settlement in the last 24 hours and over
6
billion of exchange-traded volumes so
over 8.5 billion dollars on chain
actually settling
and over six billion dollars of the
exchange volume
there was 820 000 active addresses in
the last 24 hours so almost
a million active addresses in a 24-hour
period
and the mining reward the global revenue
for miners around the world
is over 36 million dollars that's the
last 24 hours miners around the world
from that bitcoin block reward have made
36 million dollars
when we start to look at how high we are
above the cycle low it's over 35
bitcoin continues to be really strong
and all of those underlying fundamentals
continue to signal
the health of the network now when we
start to look at over the last one year
bitcoin is up 251
compared to gold which is down 11 and
the s p 500
is up 33 but if we go all the way out to
two years it's up 240
being bitcoin five years ago to today
bitcoin
is up six thousand seven hundred and
fifty six percent
over six thousand seven hundred and
fifty percent
in the last five years if you go all the
way back to ten years bitcoin is up
528 714 that's right bitcoin is up over
500 000 over the last 10 years
absolutely incredible and so when we
start to look at some of the more
detailed underlying fundamentals what we
get is
that total addresses used in the last 30
days is over
38 million addresses just a massive
massive number in the last 24 hours
there's been over
18 000 transactions almost 19
000 transactions that have happened on
the bitcoin blockchain and over the last
seven days that
high was 20 000 and the low was 14
000. so the last seven days between 14
to 20 000 transactions happening
every single day on the bitcoin
blockchain and so when you start to look
at
people who have held bitcoin for over
one year
regardless of the amount holders that
have actually held onto bitcoin for over
one year
there are 22.4 million addresses on the
bitcoin blockchain
that have bitcoin in it that have not
moved it in over a year that's
59 59
of bitcoin holders have not moved
whatever the amount of bitcoin is
in their wallet in over a year people
between 1 and 12 months
that have not moved it is over 12.46
million addresses so over a 30 day
period
anyone who's held bitcoin for more than
30 days if you add that up that ends up
being somewhere around 34 35
million wallet addresses on the bitcoin
blockchain absolutely incredible
to see continue to see that grow hash
rate today is at
98.005
or another way to look at it is if you
look at actual terra hashes per second
you can see that it is 110 tara hash
absolutely
incredible still coming off of that
bottom so what we start to see
is that the difficulty adjustment there
was a massive drop
in may and into june but it's starting
to come back currently today we are
sitting at 14.496
and then if we look at the cost per
transaction today
about 168 really really really
interesting to see all the underlying
fundamentals
after china kicked miners out of the
country coming back
and showing that the strength of the
bitcoin blockchain continues to only get
better over time now
as we begin to look at all of the
transaction volumes that 14 to 20 000
transactions per day
and then you start looking at the 22
million or so wallet addresses that have
not moved bitcoin in
under a year we can then overlay that
with what we talked about earlier in the
week
with exchanges actually pulling bitcoin
seeing their bitcoin balance pulled down
people taking bitcoin off of exchanges
and leaning into that supply squeeze
that we've been talking about for a
while that's the update for today
on bitcoin i tend to think that the
underlying fundamentals are looking very
strong
price sitting at about 38 000 39 000
and what this tells me is we're
continuing to consolidate sideways and
the fun through the end of the year
still looks
as exactly as it has over the last
couple of weeks and months so keep
paying attention to the fundamentals
don't get distracted by price
understand that every single day
it is important that you're paying
attention that you're understanding
exactly what's going on
so that's it for the bitcoin update
today we'll see you guys tomorrow
hey guys thanks so much for watching
that clip of the best business show make
sure you like and subscribe to the
channel turn on notifications so you
know when we go live every weekday
and then head to sofi.com so that you
can get an account
we can get after it